But what I'm going to do is show you.
It's sort of a simple version of what's
called the likelihood ratio test.
And here, we're basically assuming that
the cost of calling a skin pixel not
skin, is the same as cost
calling a not skin pixel, skin.
We can re-, we can re-weight these
things if the costs are different.
The likelihood ratio test
says basically, look.
It's just exactly what you think,
if the probability that it's
skin given the skew measurement,
is greater than the probability that
it's not skin, what am I going to do?
I am going to call it skin, right, that
assumes that the costs are, are equal.
So using Bayes rule,
p of skin given x is just p of
x given skin times p of skin.
P of not skin, given x, is p of x,
given not skin, times p of not skin.
So if this quantity is greater
than this whole quantity,
we're going to classify x as skin.
This is just a direct
use of Bayes' rule.
And as I said before, we would change
the weights on two sides of that
equation if, if the costs of making the,
the mistakes were not symmetric.
Allright?
So problem is that I really don't
know the prior of being skin.
Allright, I mean, I,
I dunno [INAUDIBLE] Where is the prior?
So, the one thing I'm going to do is
I'm going to assume is it's a constant.
I'm going to assume it has some number.
Allright?
So the prior for a whole bunch
of pixels that I'm looking at,
that are maybe of people or in an office
where there are people around.
The probability that something
is skin is some number.
Here's it's written as omega.
So if you give me enough training data,
that is you pay enough undergraduates to
circle all the skin areas on an image or
you do Mechanical Turk on Amazon to
indicate, to have the world out there
for a penny and a half a click to
say what's skin and what's not skin.
You could estimate the prior
that any given pixel is skin.
So, with this training data I
can also estimate that prior and
I can measure those likelihoods, right?
Those are the likely densities,
those histograms that I built,
and remember I need two histograms.
I need P of X given skin.
What are the hues that
I get on the skin?
And P of X given not skin.
Allright, so with that same
training data that I used for
estimating the prior, I can also
estimate my likelihoods, allright.
Which means I can more or
less come up with a rule.
Basically what I'm going to do is, I've
got my priors, I've got my likelihoods,
so I can just evaluate
p of x skin given x.
And if it's bigger than some number,
some theta, okay?
I'm going to classify this
thing as skin, allright?
That's it.
Given some new image,
I want to label all my pixels.
And here is a picture, this is
actually a picture of Gary Bradsky and
the thing on the right is showing you
the probability of something being skin.
And Gary actually was using this to
build perceptual user interface where
you can move your head around And
the world that you
are looking at in some virtual rendering
will change as you move your, your head.
And in fact here's two more pictures
showing you the orientation, right so
here it's pretty much straight up,
here he's, he's turned his head and
all it's doing is tracking the skin
pixels of his face, that's all, alright?
And in fact, Gary made use of this in
a cool little, track, remember we talked
about mean shift tracking just recently
actually, just a couple of lectures ago.
Gary did sort of a different
version of that called cam shift,
which was maybe a little easier to
implement sometimes, that's a pretty
highly cited paper, and it was basically
using these color distributions.
In order to be able to track your
head and change what was rendering.
In fact, the picture on your right comes
from his paper, where they were using
the Quake engine for
controlling a first-person shooter, and
if you just turned your head, okay, the
thing would just movie with you, okay?
And it was just done by,
by tracking the skin pixels.